[Musique]
six semaines mois et demi bien enfermé
lui surtout parce que j'ai pu
aller travailler et c'était bien
excité tôt le matin
nous recherchons le vélo qui était
chez sa grand-mère et ravie et
skateboard et rien que nous ayons été heureux
ici est entré le soleil du vent et moi
Cela ressemble à une mesure, eh bien, soulageant
Eh bien, la vérité est que je suis enfin très heureux
pouvoir partir car cela faisait plus d'un mois
enfermé dans ma maison et la vérité est que
Je passe un bon moment à la maison parce que j'ai
animaux de compagnie et trucs mais j'ai préféré
sortez un peu et prenez aussi de l'air frais
Je pensais que ce serait plus chaotique et
nous avons un peu peur de dire à
voir s'il y a trop de monde
c'est se comporter et nous sommes
rendre tout très propre
[Musique]
pour
un garçon de 11 ans va tourner
Eh bien, il apprécie vraiment le
arbres et ainsi de suite mais j'aurais aimé ça
plus d'espaces où je pourrais
combiner ou marcher avec le vélo
Alors nous nous sommes installés mais nous aurions
procédé un peu plus approprié à l'âge de
enfants
[Musique]
et que les amis leur manquent
amis avant tout ce qui nous manque
alors voyons si un peu plus tard maintenant
nous pouvons rester avec des amis
[Musique]